denise from lost wages assistance
concerns to portal questions we've been
getting a lot of people looking for
unemployment
answers joe moeller spoke to a few of
those people today about those important
issues
joe joins us live
yeah that's right we've been getting a
lot of people that have been contacting
our station and contacting me on my
online social media platforms a lot of
people frustrated because they don't
know whether week five the lost wages
assistance
uh money is we did reach out to dieter
and they say some of it is still being
dispersed now we also spoke to another
woman today who
says she is stuck between both the pua
and the regular ui
filing systems i'm eligible i'm one of
the people that know i'm eligible for
the fifth week many unemployment
claimants are wondering when they will
see
week five of lost wages assistance funds
i've been just waiting for it i've heard
a lot of people already received it
i got my last payment on the 10th of
november
that was the fourth one i haven't gotten
anything since nearly two weeks ago we
were told payments would begin the first
week of december
many are still waiting stressful it's
frustrating
um going week to week wondering if
they'll release it to your
card is just frustrating i shouldn't
have to keep looking
every day we did ask dieter about this
they tell us week five is still being
dispersed
some claimants say dieter reps told them
there was a delay
as far as week six that is still up in
the air and it just gets to a point
where
as an adult how much how much help do
you
can you ask everybody for i also spoke
to brenda manubach
in the spring she applied for pua the
program for gig workers and 1099 wages
but then was told due to a small w-2
income she had to apply for regular ui
benefits
started filing um ui in june been filing
that
then just last week i got a letter
saying nope
you need to file pua she says she is
stuck between portals and getting
through on the phone is nearly
impossible the last time she did get
through
was last month they said um the
adjudicators are working on june now
and i said oh that's great you know and
that was what
now it's a month ago you know
now back out here live we did ask a
woman who runs a popular assistant's
facebook page about brenda's case she
said she has come across
a few people in that same sort of
situation she says there might be
something
holding up her claim the best thing to
do even though it might be difficult
is to take that uh puary the letter that
she got recently and then to show it to
someone there and give him a call i know
it will be difficult but she says the
best thing is to do
is to try that and regarding lost wages
we did reach out to dieter about that if
we get some more information
about week six we'll be sure to pass it
along reporting live joe mulder eight
news now